[Music]  you know there is something about that  tangle of strangers pressed together for  days with nothing in common but they  need to go from one place to another and  never see each other again I see evil on  this train  a passenger has died so they got him  after all you asked us kids no no no no  not well it was in perfectly good Alfie  had his enemies indeed he was mother God  murder here God rest his soul  someone was rummaging around my cabin in  the middle of the night no one would  listen to me  if there was a murder what is going on  and there was a murderer the murderer is  with us and every one of you is a  suspect and who are you my name is lq  PAHO and i'm probably the greatest  detective in the world  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you